As many restaurants play the hospitality angle, it's important to remember that at large,...
...their business is designed to get you to order as much food and drink as possible...
...and then, of course, get you to leave quickly so they can seat the table again.
As the host guides you to a tiny table located two inches away from another party,...
...do you wonder why anybody would ever put tables that close together?
There's a very good reason for the uncomfortable proximity: to make you uncomfortable.
Diners who don't feel relaxed don't stick around.
More table turns equals more profits.
Sure, being offered a drink when you sit down is just plain polite.
It's also a way to get you to order more.
Alcohol stimulates the appetite.
When you do open the menu, your eye is likely to gravitate towards the items on the right.
That's probably where the most expensive ones are, too.
Boxes and shaded areas serve to call attention to extras.